farid thank you thank you so much for
being here let's let's talk India you
were born there
my people were camporee custodians this
is this is a temporary self-appointed
custom let's just be clear that's what
we felt we were kind of inherently
invited in some way that's basically the
excuse of the British Empire I'm sure
you were it was lost in the post yep
damn this this was an amazing election
and it's been described the result as
either an exciting or a frightening time
for Indians which is it it's mostly
exciting it's it is I think you're
absolutely right it's an amazing
election here's this guy Modi the son of
a tea seller in himself
you know saltine really humble origins
extraordinary disciplined politician
running against a political dynasty
really like no other in the world I mean
this is Rahul Gandhi the guy he was sort
of running against as prob for Prime
Minister his father was Prime Minister
his grandmother was Prime Minister his
great-grandfather was Prime Minister
it would be like Chelsea Clinton's
feeders having a child and then rock
what does it have to be like that could
it not be a different image but
everything about this election was
different from normal there's a great
bit in one of your old books where you
point out about Indian elections Indian
elections are not really national
elections at all they are rather
simultaneous regional and local
elections that have no common theme but
this changed this time didn't it he has
a huge mandate this change' and in a
fascinating way serve rather than
regional elections what you ended up
with was one big national issue and the
Congress party the old ruling party ran
on really the default message that every
third-world ruling party runs on which
is we're going to give you subsidies we
are it's a kind of you know socialism in
action and we're going to give you
subsidies because you're poor you're
entitled to them this guy said I'm gonna
run on growth and good governance I'm
not going to give you anything for free
I'm gonna I'm gonna try to get good
roads good electricity and what he
banked on what he bet on was that in
India now which is still a very poor
country there is an aspirational middle
class that doesn't want to be handed
government subsidies but once you know
the infrastructure and the good good
governance that just produces economic
growth right that's interesting because
there was at the Times of India had a
really interesting editorial yesterday
where they referred to him selling the
Indian Dream packaging the Indian Dream
to people and we know the American Dream
is clear it's catching something from a
t-shirt cannon but what what what
exactly what exactly is the Indian dream
is it just the concept of upward
mobility yeah you know the the truth is
that when you hear about this whether
it's the Indian dream or the Chinese
dream they're all really just the
American dream the American Dream was
the idea that you will do better than
your parents we franchised it exactly
that's it but but it's like a supernova
just as it's catching on everywhere else
it's imploding here at home why
why do you why does every analogy you
use have to be so appalling li- hi this
is HBO is that's true so we're testing
the limits that's wrong it's not it's
not TV it's appalling li- that's
basically uh do you can you stick around
to talk online because this is a much
bigger discussion we have time to get
into here as long as there are a couple
more photographs you're gonna post I
think the worst thing is I actually have
one worse than that and I chickened out
but if you want to watch an extended
version of this interview online go here
at fareed zakaria ladies and gentlemen
we will return the following Sunday at
the fantastic two weeks goodnight
Oh